Wie ist es, Jan?
Guten Tag. Ich heiße Mustafa Cilik und ich bin hier auf der Station als Assistenz, als Tätig.
Herr Doktor, ich habe Ihren Namen nicht verstanden. Können Sie bitte langsam wiederholen?
Ja, ich heiße Mustafa Cilik und ich bin hier auf der Station als Assistenz, als Tätig.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen.
Ja, gerne, Doktor Cilik. Ich freue mich.
Ich werde Ihnen zuerst ein paar Algemene Fragen stellen und danach werden wir über die Aktuellen Bescheid werden.
Okay? Ja, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Hermann Hesse.
Hermann?
Hesse.
Können Sie Ihren Vorname, Nachname, büchstabieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist Hermann, schreibt sich H, E, R, MA, N.
Ja, okay.
Und der Nachname ist Hesse, schreibt sich H, E, S, E, Hesse.
Ja, okay, Herr Hesse.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 70 Jahre alt jetzt.
70. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Er ist weiter im März 1953.
1953, okay. Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ungefähr 80 Kilo.
80 Kilo und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich mache mal 1,80 Meter groß.
1,80 Meter, okay.
Vielleicht habe ich jetzt ein bisschen abgenommen und habe viel Größe.
Ja, okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Was kann ich für Sie tun, Herr Hesse?
Herr Doktor, mein Hausarzt schickt mich zu Ihnen.
Und zwar muss ich jetzt ein bisschen ausholen über meine Beschwerden.
Und zwar kann ich sagen, dass ungefähr seit Anfang des Jahres, also es war
nach Weihnachten, Neujahr, habe ich gemerkt, dass ich doch Schwierigkeiten habe
mit der Luft, das war nicht so früher, das habe ich gemerkt,
als ich jetzt Treppen gestiegen bin.
Also ich habe ein Haus, das hat 3 Stockwerke.
Und früher war das kein Problem, hat man gemerkt,
wenn ich in 3. Stock gelaufen bin, dann hatte ich mal gemerkt,
dass das nicht so wie früher war, dass ich ein bisschen knapp war
von der Luft war.
Das ist 5-6 Monate, können wir sagen, ja?
Ja, 5 Monate, vielleicht, ja, 5, 7, ungefähr.
Und das habe ich dann einfach so, ja, zur Kenntnis,
dann dachte ich, ja, okay, ich bin auch älter geworden,
vielleicht ist auch da dran, dass die Kondition nicht gut ist.
Aber das hat sich dann so langsam, schleichend, verschlechtert.
Und ich konnte dann praktisch merken,
dass ich da immer weniger Luft bekommen habe.
Und seit 3 Tagen habe ich so starke Luftnot, nicht in Ruhe,
aber sobald ich ein bisschen bewege, also wenn ich in 1. Stock laufe,
merke ich, dass ich schon knapp bin.
Das hat sich deutlich verschlechtert in den letzten 3 Tagen.
3 Tage auch in Ruhe haben Sie?
Ruhe, in Ruhe, nicht, aber bei kleiner Belastung.
Wenn ich jetzt in ein Stockwerk steige, dann habe ich das massiv Luftnot.
Und das war früher nicht so.
Und deswegen bin ich zum Haushalt gegangen, ja, heute Morgen.
Und dann hat er mich abgehört, sagt er, ja, ich hätte Wasser in der Lunge
und ich müsse ins Krankenhaus gehen.
Ja, okay.
Du hast etwas richtiges gemacht, ja, per heiße.
Okay.
Haben Sie beim Luftnot oder begleitenden Luftnot,
hatten Sie, hatten Sie, wussten auch?
Also, habe ich mich, hatte, hatte mich auch gefragt.
Ich wollte sagen, vielleicht ein bisschen, aber nicht so stark.
Kann ich nicht so ständig, dass ich es starken wusste?
Vielleicht wusste ich ein bisschen mehr als früher, aber...
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie auch Auswurf?
Nein, ich habe nicht Auswurf.
Okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für diese Beschwerden?
Ich meine, Sie haben schon gesagt, bei Belastung haben Sie Luftnot.
Ja.
Gibt es andere Auslöse, haben Sie bemerkt?
Das ist mir sonst nichts aufgefallen, Herr Doktor.
Okay.
Haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen, per heiße?
Nein, ich habe mich einfach dann ausgeruht, oder...
Nein, ich habe mich...
Ich wusste auch nicht, welche Medikamente dagegen helfen könnten.
Okay, ja.
Hatten Sie Unfall?
Aktuell?
Ja, in den letzten sechs Monaten?
Nein, habe ich keinen Unfall.
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber, Schutteilprost, Nachtschweiß oder Kaltschweißigkeit?
Nein.
Also, ich habe mal eben März mal Infektionen gehabt, aber so war eher so ein bisschen wie Grippe.
Aber aktuell habe ich keine Probleme.
Okay.
Haben Sie Verstopfung oder Durchwahl?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Kann ich nicht sagen, nein.
Okay.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie fühlen sich müde, ja, richtig?
Also, nur wenn ich Luftnot habe, dann habe ich diese, aber sonst kann ich nicht sagen, dass ich müde bin, nein.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit, Herr Hesse?
Normal, würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Zum Beispiel, wenn Sie nicht flachen, kriegen Sie Genugluft?
Was meinen Sie?
Ich habe es nicht ganz bestanden, Doktor, ich würde sagen. Was nochmal wiederholt?
Wenn Sie flachen legen, kriegen Sie Genugluft?
Was meinen Sie?
Ich glaube, das geht, ja.
Ich habe keine großen Probleme bisher.
Okay.
Sonst haben Sie keine Probleme beim Schlafen, ja?
Eigentlich nicht, Herr Doktor.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, Herr Doktor, ich kriege das gleich mit 80, vielleicht 1, 2 kg hoch oder runter, aber um die Erklärung.
Okay.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzstolben?
Nichts mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Okay.
Okay, das ist ja.
Haben Sie irgendetwas für Erkrankungen?
Ich meine Blutdruck oder Schilddruckstörungen?
Blutdruck ist gut bei mir, aber ich habe keine Probleme.
Oder Zuckerkrankheiten vielleicht?
Auch Zucker ist nicht bekannt.
Ich hatte mal eine Gallenstange, bin an der Gallenblase operiert worden,
für 20 Jahre bestimmt von her.
Ja, vor 20 Jahren, ja.
Und dann hatte ich mal, ich hatte eine Hüft-Athrose.
Hüft-Athrose, okay.
Und dann habe ich auch eine Protese bekommen,
eine Total-Protese auf der rechten Seite.
Und hatte dann nach der Operation auch eine Trombose nebenbei gehabt.
Und für drei Monate auch dann Spritzen machen.
Nach dem Operation, ja.
Ja, das war nach der Operation.
Das war jetzt auch schon ungefähr fünf Jahre, glaube ich so.
Zürsait haben Sie bemerkt, geschwölten Beine
oder gibt es Probleme bei der Beine?
Beine, nein, die sind jetzt nicht geschwölten, Doktor.
Und keine Verfahrer- oder Fahrveränderung auf der Beine?
Aufgefahren, nein.
Okay, nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente regelmäßig oder gelegenlich ein?
Also manchmal Ibuprofen, wenn ich Beschwerden habe in den Gelenken,
ansonsten habe ich keine regelmäßigen Medikamente.
Wie viel Milligramm Ibuprofen, das ist wichtig.
Also diese normale 400, die man auch kaufen kann.
Okay, haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Da ist mir nichts bekannt, nein.
Okay, okay.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Nein, nein.
Sehr gut.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nur gelegenlich an Wochenende vielleicht, wenn die Gesellschaft,
man glaswein vielleicht.
Ja, gelegenlich können wir sagen.
Gelenklich, ja.
Die nächste Frage ist eine Routine Frage.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit dem Drogen?
Mit Drogen?
Ja, ich meine, kann das nicht.
Okay, was machen Sie wirklich, Herr Hesse?
Ich bin Rentner.
Ja, aber früher?
Da habe ich Fabrik gearbeitet,
die Fabrik heißt ATE,
Bremsen hergestellt für Autos, Bremsklitz.
Bremsehersteller.
Ja.
Gibt es irgendwelche Substanz in dieser Fabrik?
Zum Beispiel Asbest, haben Sie schon mal gehört?
Ich glaube, wenn es...
Das war mal früher so, ja.
Da haben Sie bestellt, aber früher,
da haben Sie, glaube ich, mit Asbest Bremsen gemacht.
Letzte Jahre, wo ich gearbeitet habe,
da war kein Asbest gewesen.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Sind Sie nachher heiratet?
Ja, sind verheiratet.
Okay, wohnen Sie zusammen mit Ihrer Frau?
Ja.
Okay, das ist gut.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe Kinder, drei Kinder,
auch schon erwachsen, sind alle außer Haus.
Ah, das ist wunderschön.
Ich glaube, diese Kinder sind gesund.
Die sind so weit gesund.
Okay, das ist gut.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Also nicht regelmäßig, nein.
Wenn dann echt spazieren, wandern vielleicht.
In der Familie gibt es die Pfeile von Krebs
oder Erkrankungen oder chronische Erkrankungen.
Haben Sie daran erinnern?
Krebs, ich habe keine Beine,
weil mein Eltern kannte gewesen.
Mein Vater hatte Herzprobleme.
Er hatte auch Hungerprobleme.
Er ist dann auch an Herzschwäche gestorben.
Und bei der Mutter hatte auch verschiedene andere Sachen.
Diabetes und Bluthochdruck.
Die hat am Schlaganfall gestorben.
Ja, wegen Schlaganfall gestorben.
Und Ihr Vater ist an Herzschwäche gestorben.
Das war dann die Aussage,
dass das Herz nicht mehr geräumt hat und gestorben.
Okay, es ist schon ein bisschen zu viel.
Ja, möchten Sie etwas hinterfügen, Herr Hesse?
Ich hatte auch irgendwas im Kopf, was ich sagen wollte.
Aber das habe ich jetzt vergessen, glaube ich.
Vielleicht kommt das noch in lautes Gespräch.
Okay, Sie fühlen sich nicht müde, glaube ich.
Haben Sie Brutzschmerzen oder irgendwelche Schmerzen?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Ja, das haben wir schon.
Ich überlege, da habe ich schon so ein leichter Druckgefühl
auf der linken Seite der Brust.
Das ist auch schon die ganze Zeit, in den letzten Monaten.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das von dem Wasser kommt,
das der Arzt festgestellt hat.
Das habe ich gemerkt.
Also ist jetzt kein Schmerz,
in dem sind eher so ein Druckgefühl.
Seit einem Monat, ja?
Einige Monate, glaube ich.
Einige Monate, ja.
Okay, jetzt gibt es diese Schmerzen.
Jetzt fühlen Sie sich diese Schmerzen.
Schmerzen habe ich keine Druckgefühle.
Ja, Druckgefühl habe ich, ja.
Das ist jetzt gleich, aber ich nehme jetzt keine Schmerzmedikamente dagegen ein.
Okay, ja.
Jetzt, Herr Hesse, ich erkläre Ihnen,
was ich machen werde.
Doktor, es ist mir eingefallen.
Ich habe auch etwas gesagt,
wo Sie mich nach den Krankheiten gefragt haben.
Also ich hatte mal als Kind auch eine Tuberkulose gehabt.
Ich stand damals mit Medikamentmann,
und da habe ich nie wieder etwas zu tun gehabt damit.
Okay, als Kind sie war, ja.
Tuberkulose gehabt, okay.
Aber seit dieser Infektion haben Sie bisher kein Problem, ja?
Nee, nie wieder, nie wieder.
Ich habe nicht mehr eingefallen.
Und an den übrigen Kinderkrankheiten hatte ich auch so Mums und Röteln, Masern.
Also ich hatte die üblichen Kinderkrankheiten auch gehabt.
Ja, Herr Hesse, jetzt machen wir so.
Du, Herr Hesse, werde ich ein EKG durchführen,
um möglicherweise Herzprobleme auszuschließen.
Das ist wichtig für uns.
Ja.
Und dann werde ich Ihre Metallparameter überprüfen.
Was ist das?
Ja, was die Metallparameter sind.
Diese Parameter sind, ich meine, ich kontrolliere Ihre Herzfrequenz,
Blutdruck und Körpertemperatur.
Außerdem überprüfe ich Ihre Sauerstoffsetzung.
Und werde ich ausführliche, körperliche Untersuchungen machen.
Ja.
Und dann nehme ich ein bisschen Blut für weitere Diagnostik.
Und werde ich informieren, sie schritt für schritt.
Ja.
Und dann können wir zusammen über Ihre Situation sprechen.
Was ist dem Wasser, Herr Doktor?
Muss man das abziehen?
Ja, das höre ich.
Ja, verbunden.
Können Sie bitte wiederholen?
Was ist mit dem Wasser?
Der Haushalt meinte, in Krankenhaus müssten wir das Wasser abziehen.
Wasser abziehen, ja.
Ja.
So erst werde ich diese Untersuchung und diagnostische Massnahmen durchführen.
Und dann werden wir uns entscheiden, ob es andere Massnahmen machen.
Weil die Luft ja das Problem ist.
Ja, aber nach meiner Meinung, ich bin mir ja nicht sicher.
Aber es kann eine Probleme wegen Ihrer alten Arbeit sein.
Weil es ist eine beschädigte Substanz für unsere Lungen.
Es könnte sein, aber ich bin mir ja nicht sicher jetzt.
Ja, wir müssen diese Massnahmen erledigen.
Okay, ich dachte, Sie müssten das Wasser abziehen, weil der Haus sagt,
Sie müssten das Wasser über 1,5 Liter Wasser in der Lunge.
Und deswegen dachte ich, Sie müssten das Wasser abziehen.
Ja, das kann sein.
Es gibt eine Krankheit für Motorracks.
Es kann Wasser sein zwischen Lungen und Brustkorb.
Dieser Wasser kann diese Probleme verursachen.
Aber wir wissen jetzt nichts sicher.
Wir müssen jetzt Untersuchung machen.
Und außerdem können wir einen Röntgenaufnahme von Brustkorb machen.
Okay, gut.
Und ja, das war.
Alles klar, einfach dann, Herr Doktor.
Dann machen Sie etwas richtig.
Ja, ich vertreibe.
Aber Kollege, andere Fragen?
Nein, das ist gut.
Ein weniger Fragen.
Genau, was gibt es für Fragen?
Ultraschall ist keine Frage.
Aber was gibt es für Anonyse-Fragen noch, die sich eine Patientin gefragt hätten?
Müssen Sie in der Nacht zur Tour gehen?
Ja, das ist eine Frage.
Einmal muss er zur Nacht zur Tour gehen, wie immer, wie seit Jahren.
Ich verstehe.
Bitte schön.
Ist Ihre Beine normal?
Nein.
Habt ihr gefragt, dass die Beine normal sind?
Okay.
Und wie viele Kissen benüsst ihr zum Schlafen?
Ein Kissen normal.
Okay, danke.
Ich finde es nicht, ob diese gefragt wurden.
Aber Sie treten beim Wasserlassen oder beim Sturrgang Schwierigkeiten?
Er hat Sturrgang Probleme gefragt, aber da gab es keine Probleme.
Was erlassen, gab es auch keine Probleme.
Danke.
Da wurde gefragt, Reise an Anonyse, habe ich gesehen irgendwo?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Es gab aber keine Reise, die letzten 1-2 Jahre.
Sie sind vollständig gegen Corona?
Anonyse hat jetzt keine neuen Impfungen bekommen seit der Kindheit.
Also vermutlich nicht.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass irgendwelche Luftknoten, Vergrößerung am Hals oder Axelhöhe oder Leisten?
Hat er nicht gemerkt, nein.
Okay, danke.
Herzlassen hat er gefragt, hat er nicht gemerkt, Impfdatus ist auch gefragt worden.
Ja, das haben wir noch.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie das Gefühl, dass Sie unter dem Wasser atmen?
Was meinen Sie damit genau?
Wie Luftnot, aber das zeigt unsere Emotisiö oder Astempelä.
Ich habe es glaube ich nicht ganz verstanden, aber er ist nicht so, dass er es so wie ertrinken meinen Sie unter Wasser oder?
Nein, wie unter Wasser atmen.
Unter Wasser atmen, was ist unter Wasser atmen?
Das ist mit der Zeit.
Ja, Luft braucht mehr.
Ja, bei Belastung hat er das Gefühl, dass er nicht genug Luft bekommt, ja.
Also zunehmend.
Noch eine Frage.
Ja.
War Ihnen schwindelig oder über?
Hat er nicht beobachtet, nein.
Hatten Sie solche Beschwerden früher gehalten?
Gute Frage.
Nein, das kennt er nicht.
Das ist zum ersten Mal so seit dem halben Jahr.
Aber der Patient hat gesagt, seit sechs Monaten diese Beschwerden zunehmend, ja, schleichend.
Ja, zunehmend.
Ähnliche Beschwerden müssen wir fragen, oder?
Ähnliche Beschwerden? Früher, meinen Sie, vor sechs Monaten, oder?
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Müssen wir fragen, ich habe eine Frage für Sie.
Also kann man fragen, er hat aber jetzt vorher keine Probleme gehabt mit Atmung.
Aber kann man natürlich fragen, ob es das früher mal gab, wenn er wieder gegangen ist, wie der kommt, ja.
Kann man auf jeden Fall fragen, ja.
Husten, glaube ich, habe ich gesehen, das hat er schon gefragt.
Das ist ein trockener Husten, aber auch gering, nicht viel.
Leichter Husten als er trocken, kein Auswurf.
Infektionen wurden gefragt, glaube ich, das ist noch ein wichtiger Punkt.
Ja, Sie haben schon Grippe gesagt.
Genau, so ein Grippalinfekt hat er gesagt, ja.
Und, ähm, was habe ich noch an Problemen?
Ich denke, alle Fragen hat geschickt, Herr Tujan.
Ja, das war schon so weit, das komplett.
Können wir als erstes geschickt beginnen?
Mhm, gerne her.
Bitte schön, Mustafa.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt. Ich habe einen neuen Patient.
Darf ich Ihnen ihn vorstellen?
Ja, bitte schön, gerne.
Der Patient ist Hermann Hesse.
Er ist 70 Jahre alt und 80 Kilogramm schwer und 1,80 Meter groß.
Er hat sich wegen seit sechs Monaten bestehender Luftnot vorgestellt.
Und bei der Belastung hat er diese Beschwerden.
Aber seit drei Tagen hat sich diese Beschwerden verschlecht.
Berichtete der Patient.
Er hat leichten Husten, aber das war trockenen Husten, nicht produktiv Husten.
Und, ja, er hat leichten ein Druckgefühl im Brust.
Deswegen habe ich einen EKG durchgeführt.
Wo rechts oder links?
Links, ja, links, ja.
Er hat schon mehr gezeigt.
In der letzten Zeit hatte er ein Grippeinfektion,
aber das war es.
Er berichtete keine komplikationliche Infektion.
Als begleitende Symptoma berichtete er nichts.
Keine begleitende Symptoma.
Und vegetativ anamnesisch ist unauffällig.
Und, ja, er hat,
bei den Patienten wurde die Kolesistik durchgeführt vor 20 Jahren.
Und er hatte Hüftartose,
deswegen wurde total endoprotest durchgeführt bei den Patienten.
Vor Kurzem erst, oder wie lange ist das her?
Nein, das habe ich nie gefragt.
Aber das ist wichtig, glaube ich, nach der Operation hat er Trombose.
Und höchstwahrscheinlich hat er die Patientin abgereicht.
Was hat er gemacht?
Er hat gesagt, er hatte eine Spritze nach dieser Trombose.
Aber das war Heparin, nach meiner Meinung.
Gelegentlich nimmt er Ibuprofen ein, das war 400 mg.
Und er hat keine Allergie, er raucht nicht.
Und er trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol, er hat keine Erfährung mit Drogen.
Ihr Vater und Mutter sind gestorben.
Und welchem Lebensjahr habe ich nicht gefragt.
Ihr Vater hatte Herzprobleme und Lungenprobleme.
Ihre Mutter hatte Diabetes mellitus und arterialipertoni.
Mutter ist an Schlaganfall gestorben.
Dosyalan am Nestisch berichtete er, er ist Rentner.
Und er hat in einer Fabrik gearbeitet.
Das war eine bremse Hersteller dieser Fabrik.
Und er hat viele Asbestos eingeatmet in der Fabrik.
Asbestos war darin.
Er ist verheiratet und hat drei Kinder.
Und kein Sport treibt er.
An am Nestischer Aufgaben deuten Stapelungen oder Pynomokonios.
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Pynomokonios.
Und durch diese Diagnose erhält man.
Macht Pynomokonios ein Flöreerguss?
Pynomokonios macht Fibrosis.
Hat er nicht gesagt, der Hausarzt hat ihn geschickt wegen Flöreerguss?
Ja, ehrlich gesagt, das verstehe ich.
Aber warum hat der Hausarzt den Bergus nicht gedacht?
Er hat den Untersuchung gesagt.
Dann können wir nach untersuchen.
Wie würden Sie den Patienten untersuchen, wenn Sie den Laptopferwerkuss haben?
Oder was für Untersuchungsbefunde können Sie erheben?
Wir können einen Röntgenaufnahme da kommen.
Zuerst müssen Sie etwas machen.
Ihre Hände haben ihre Ohren, Augen.
Ich untersuche körperlich.
Ich höre den Lungen ab.
Wenn ich den Lungengeräusche erniedrig ist,
können wir sagen, es kann ein Erguss oder Fibrosis sein.
Was hören Sie bei einer normalen Lunge, wenn Sie abhören?
Lungengeräusche.
Wie nennt man das?
Wenn es normal befunden ist, dass Sie hören, mit Stethoskop, wenn Sie abhören.
Wie bezeichnen Sie das?
Einatmung und Ausatmung.
Sie hören Atemgeräusche.
Wie sind Atemgeräusche bei einem gesunden Menschen?
Normalerweise.
Bei einem gesunden Menschen sind Atemgeräusche normal.
Wie bezeichnet man das?
Ja, das weiß ich nicht.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Was kann das Atemgeräusche noch sein?
Ja, Atemgeräusche können erniedrig sein.
Abgeschwächtet man das?
Ja, das weiß ich nicht.
Was ist die Differenziatdiagnose, wenn Sie das Atemgeräusche haben?
Die Pynomotorax.
Nein, das weiß ich nicht.
Sie haben neben den normalen, vesikulierten Atemgeräusche
noch andere Phänomene beim Ausgutieren, die Sie hören können.
Wie kann es sein, kennen Sie da welche?
Wenn zum Beispiel eine Pynomonie gibt,
dass hört man da?
Ja, zum Beispiel eine Loubertpynomonie, können wir
ein la Prüch-Atemgeräusch sich verandern.
Ja, wir können rüber,
aber dass, wie man auf Dob ...
gibt es zwei grobe Gruppen von Rasselgeräuschen, einmal die Beuchten und die trockenen Rasselgeräusche.
Die Beuchten und Rasselgeräusche hören Sie wo, bei welcher Erkrankung zum Beispiel?
Ja, zum Beispiel Kardiak-Öderm, ja, zum Beispiel Kartinfizienz, können wir hören und trocken,
können wir diese Phenomokonges vielleicht hingen? Ja, kann mal Spaß hingen, ja, aber klassische
Trockenrasselgeräusche sind in dieser spastischen Geräusche wie Bomen, Gimel, Beifen, ja.
Was hier, okay.
Gut, ja.
Das ist das erste Mal, das können wir sagen.
Gut, jetzt haben Sie Auskretation gemacht, haben bei dem Patient an der linken Seite
einen abgeschwätsten Atemgeräusch gehört, ja.
Das ist ein Transiadiagnosis, dann einmal so ein Motor, das haben Sie gesagt.
Zweite, was hier wie Folch, Ergus, was ist noch, drei, und was ist noch der Möglichkeit noch?
Das ist ein chronische Fibrosis, können wir sagen.
Kann auch viel Spaß sein, ja, oder auch noch?
Was noch, es kann eine Brunschial-Probleme, eine Brunschial-Obstüktion sein, können wir,
die Atelik da, aber ich möchte, ich würde Krebs oder Arsynom sein, aber keine Rauchen,
keine...
Wir sind erstmal bei der Körperlündersuchung, ich habe es noch später, ja.
Also Sie haben abgehört, aufgehobenes oder abgeschwätsten Atembräuch auf der rechten Seite.
Wenn es klassiker ist, ist sogar diese ansteigende Demosolinie, die kann Sie was Laterales dann höher,
als praktisch medial, als ansteigend ist es manchmal, kann manchmal sein.
Und was machen Sie noch, nach dem Auskultieren?
Nach dem Auskultieren, ich mache, ja, ich mache Durantgenau-Name.
Nein, mit der Hand.
Ja, ich mache Perkussion.
Ja, was hören Sie da?
Wenn es Ergus gibt, wir hören andere Geräusche, wenn wir Perkussion machen.
Ja, wie nennt man das?
Ja, wie nennt man?
Also ein Klopschall, ne?
Ja, Klopschall.
Wie ist der Normal, der Klopschall bei den normalen Menschen, wie nennt man den?
Klopschall ist normal.
Ja, es gibt einen Fachbegriff dafür, wenn er normal ist, ist er ein Sonorerklopschall.
Aber das war nur auf dem Torax, zum Beispiel auf dem Sonorabschall.
Nee, Klopschall ist auch im Bauch, kann man auch im Bauch haben.
Im Klopschall kann man bezeichnen, der Lunge normal ist Sonor.
Was es Technologisches, entweder zu viel oder zu wenig sein, wie nennt man das?
Ja, Sonor das ist mein
Ja, das ist der Klopschall, sagt man dann.
Ja, der Klopschall.
Also es gibt noch ein paar andere Untersuchungen, aber die lassen wir jetzt mal weg.
Jetzt haben Sie ausgotiert, Sie haben abgeschwächtes Atemgeräusch gehört, rechts, Sie haben Klopschall gedämpft.
Bei der Ausgotation kann man auch manchmal hören, dass oberhalb des Erguses so ein Entfaltungsknistern manchmal da ist,
dass die Lunge sich noch entfalten kann, das ist bei Parapenharmonischen, bei Ergüsten auszutrücken.
Gut, jetzt haben Sie noch andere Möglichkeiten weiterzumachen.
Jetzt haben wir die Körperchönesung gemacht, was machen Sie weiter?
Nach der Körperchönesuchung.
Ja.
Ich fühle einen Grundgernaufnahme von Torax durch.
Was geht manchmal schneller in der Notaufnahme, was ist manchmal schneller, machbar und vielleicht sogar besser?
Die Pyrometrie können wir machen.
Das ist ein aufwendiger.
Was geht meistens sehr schnell in der Notaufnahme, hat eigentlich jede Notaufnahme das Gerät.
Wo wir uns seinen Erguss ganz schnell feststellen können.
Der Ultraschall?
Ja, richtig.
Dass Sie sensitiv sind, die Methode oder einen Plurre-Erguss festzustellen.
Genau.
Okay.
Können Sie auf jeden Fall noch einmal ein Röntgenbild machen?
Ja.
Und so erst, ich habe schon gesagt, mit allen Parameter habe ich geprüft.
Das war richtig.
Das war richtig, ja.
Das macht man auf jeden Fall.
Aber dann können Sie genauso langsam weiter machen nach Routine.
Ja, ja.
Für die Pyrometrie und den Ultraschall, dann Röntgenaufnahme des Brut-Skorts.
Ja.
Dann, ja, Bullet-Abnahme, ja, das können wir machen.
Das kann man machen, aber wenn der Passant Luftnot hat, dann kann man ja schon, wenn man den Erguss gesehen hat, was machen dann direkt?
Direkt.
Sauerstoff-Sättigung.
Also, klar, mein Sauerstoff-Sättigung ist so vielleicht grenzwertig in Italison.
Ja, wir können Sauerstoff geben, ja.
Ja, das können Sie, aber wenn Sie jetzt im Ultraschall einen riesen Erguss nachgewiesen haben, dann, was machen Sie dann?
Wir machen diese Erguss herausnehmen und ja, Plurapunkt und Pluraparazentes, ja, richtig.
Genau.
Erstens, damit Sie dem Patient akut helfen können, ja, weil man hat da noch mehr Platz.
Und breitens, machen Sie das aus diagnostischen Gründen, ja.
Ja, ja.
Warum machen Sie das?
Ich habe eine Frage, Herr Oberhör.
Wenn wir keine Pluralepidion sehen oder Erguss sehen, dann, was machen wir so erst?
Ich glaube, Sauerstoff abbreichen, ja, das ist so.
Also, wenn Sie auch im Röntgen nichts sehen, dann machen Sie ein CT.
Ja, okay.
Und das CT machen Sie aber sowieso.
Ja, natürlich, ja.
Also, auch wenn Sie Erguss sehen, muss man auch ein CT machen, dann nochmal, ja.
Aber nicht als Notfallmaßnahme, sondern als weitere diagnostische Schritte zu machen, ja.
Aber als Maßnahme, Sie haben viel Erguss, haben funktiert, damit da ein bisschen Luft bekommen kann.
Was machen Sie mit dem Erguss?
Ja, dieser Erguss ist sehr wichtig für uns.
Wir sollen diese Substanz, histopathologische Untersuchungen machen.
Ob es Krebs oder Anterezelle gibt oder wegen, ob es eine Infektion Erreger gibt.
Wir wollen ja diese Flüssigkeit untersuchen.
Und mit der Physiostologie und Mikrobiologen.
Was ist manchmal der erste Untersuchung, den man macht?
Ja, wir können diese Erguss Transuda oder Extuda bemerken, wenn es weiß ist.
Können wir denken, dass es wegen einer Infektion sein wird.
Aber natürlich, wir können es nicht.
Wenn es weiß ist, dann ist es Eiter, dann ist es ein Plurämpie.
Das ist das Worst Case, das ist das Stimmste.
Wie sieht ein normaler Pluräguss aus?
Normaler Pluräguss, wie sieht es aus, wenn Sie einen normalen Pluräguss haben?
Eigentlich meine ich ganz normal, aber Sie haben recht, den sieht man ja nicht.
Wenn man Patienten aufmobbert, dann sieht man das.
Aber sagen wir mal, es ist ein Transuda, wie sieht er aus, wenn Sie die Erguss punktieren?
Ja, das sieht wie ein Wasser.
Wie klares Wasser oder wie sieht es aus?
Nach meiner Meinung wie klar, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Also ein bisschen geldlich verfärbt, wie so sehr röse Flüssigkeit sieht es aus.
Wie kann Exodat aussehen?
Exodat ist weiss, weiss ist das Eiter.
Also Exodat sieht aus, wie Transodaten manchmal, das kann man nicht unterscheiden teilweise.
Manchmal kann aber Exodat so ein bisschen verfärbt sein in Form von Bernsteinfarben.
Bernsteinfarben.
Bernstein ist auf türkisch Kerrivar.
Kerrivar weiss ich auch nicht.
Erdibar ist Bernstein, oder?
Und was kann noch sein, wie kann er noch aussehen, wenn Exodat ist?
Wir können Hematom sehen oder Blut sehen.
Also hemorragische Pluräguss richtig sehen.
Genau, wir können Sie optisch schon mal grob einschätzen.
Und wie unterscheiden Sie Transodat vom Exodat?
So erst Billigdiagnose können wir unterscheiden.
Manchmal sehen die gleich aus.
Wir können Protein-Elektrophores vielleicht machen.
Oder einfach Protein-Gehalt messen.
Damit können Sie festlegen, dass Exodat-Transodat ist.
Was für Ursachen gibt es, wenn Sie einen Transodat haben?
Das ist dann als Ursache wahrscheinlich.
Ich habe schon gesagt, es kann ein Paraneoplastik-Sendrom verursachen.
Kannst du dat eher selten?
Ja, aber ein viral Infektion kann verursacht werden.
Ja, wobei viral Entzündungen dann auch oft schon exodative Veränderungen machen können.
Das würde ich glauben, dass es eher exodat ist, aber wenn es nicht so stark ist.
Aber Sie haben schon gefragt, wo das Ego-Send mal herkommen kann.
Was haben Sie gefragt?
Ob bei dicke Beinheit haben Sie gefragt?
Das ist Unfall, habe ich gefragt.
Aber Sie haben auch nach dicken Beinen, aber die Beine dick sind.
Ja, ja, ja, ich meine, Lungenembolli.
Bei Lungenembolli sind die Beine aber nicht dick. Wo sind die Beine dick, bei welcher Krankheit?
Lämpfüden oder Lämpfandüden können da auch nicht.
Sie sind jetzt mal Internist und denken mal an ein wichtiges Volk im Körper.
Ja, Herzinsuffizien.
Können wir Lungenöden und Transodat-Pleural-Effision machen?
Richtig, den Beispiel genau.
Die Herzinsuffizien sind das klassische Beispiel oder auch alle Formen von Hypoprotein oder Hypoalbumin im Ehe, z.B. Leberzirose.
Können wir auch sagen, General Insuffizienz können wir diese Situation haben?
Kann auch mal sein, ja, richtig.
Das für mich Beispiel Transodats, häufig für Transodats ist Herz.
Und das Exodat haben Sie schon gesagt, es ist ein bayerische Veränderung, können wir Exodate machen?
Ja, die Global Infiltration von TREPS-Selle können diese Exodaperuzachen, außer dem Paraneoplastycenter,
vielleicht können Peruzachen und außer dem Infektionen können diese Exodaperuzachen.
Welche Infektionen ist denn so, was man typisch auch immer denken muss an Exodats?
Steppe Kokos Pynomonia.
Das ist ja das normale Loperprinz.
Aber ich meine, es war spezifischer. Eine spezifische Entzündung.
Ja.
Kennen Sie eine spezifische Entzündung?
Ja, ich könnte schon, aber jetzt, das kann ich nicht daran erinnern.
Hat der Patient in der Anamäse etwas angegeben?
Ja, Grippe hat er gesagt.
Ja, zum Beispiel, aber es ist keine spezifische Entzündung.
Kokos Influencer.
Manchmal nicht.
Was berichtet, als Kind hat er etwas gehabt?
Ja, Tuberkulose, ja.
Ja, richtig. Also bei Exodats müssen Sie auch immer an Tuberkulose denken, ja?
Okay.
Ja.
Das verstehe ich.
Gut, okay.
Also Sie haben ihn punktiert, 2 Liter haben Sie rausgeholt und das war Exodat, leicht hemorragisch.
Da haben die Grobiologie gemacht und haben jetzt keinen Nachweis.
Und waren es auch keine Humorzellen zu sehen.
Was machen Sie das Nächstes?
Ja, Nächstes.
CT haben wir gesagt.
Ja, Torax CT sollen wir machen.
Genau.
Okay.
Und Sie haben ja gesagt, Sie haben mir verdacht, dass das eine Erkrankung ist, die mit seinem Beruf zu tun hat, gell?
Ja.
Durch Astest.
Aber die Schuße ist nicht pnomokonios, sondern eine andere Krankheit, die ja als bestbedingt ist.
Ja.
Das fällt mir pnomokonios ein, Astestosis.
Und ich glaube, wir können das nachweisen, durch ein CT zu haben.
Also pnomokonios kann man im CT zwar sehen, aber Sie können die Ursache nicht finden.
Aber was?
Ja.
Eine Krankheit macht dann Astest, eine böserte Krankung.
Was ist denn eine böserte Krankung für die Astest?
Ah ja, ja, ja, ja, Medutalia.
Ja, pleurer Medutalia.
Und da können Sie im CT auch verschiedene Zeichen sehen, zum Beispiel die Pleurer, Plex oder
diese Tafelberg, wenn man Ihnen sagt, man hat auch Tomoren direkt.
Gut, dann haben Sie CT gemacht.
Sie sehen nur Ergust, sonst keine Auffälligkeiten, keinen Tumor.
Was machen Sie als nächstes?
Sie kriegen also Mikrobiologie frei, keine Tumorzünderweisexudat.
Was machen Sie als nächstes bei den Patienten?
Die Promethe, sollen wir jeden Fall machen, glaube ich.
Was machen Sie?
Promethe, ja, Absoluten.
Promethe, ja.
Ja.
Wo hat Restriktion, klar, weil er Ergust hat, aber sonst keine Auffälligkeiten.
Aber was macht das zu klären, die Diagnose?
Ich habe jetzt Restriktion Probleme, richtig?
Haben Sie doch Ergust?
Ja.
Ja, im CT haben wir nichts gesehen, dann können wir vielleicht bronchial Spiegelung
oder bronchial Lavage, das wollen wir machen, vielleicht.
Broncoscopi, meine ich.
Broncoscopi kann man machen, aber im CT hat er jetzt in den zentralen Bronchen keine
Auffälligkeiten gehabt, es ist alles nur Ergust gewesen.
Kann man mal machen, ja, ist richtig?
Ja.
Okay, da haben Sie auch gemacht, auch nichts gefunden, was machen Sie als nächstes?
Nächstes.
Ergust geht nicht weg, hat keine Entzündungsparameter, also,
und keine Herzensbezirien, was machen Sie?
Ja.
Dann müssen Sie das Ganze nochmal versuchen, histologisch zu klären,
und das macht man am besten mit einer Videothoracoscopy, ja.
Videothoracoscopy.
Videothoracoscopy, dann die Plurat zu inspizieren und jedenfalls Proben zu entnehmen
aus der Plurat, weil die sind ja, Biopsy, genau.
Ja, Biopsy sollen wir machen.
Ja, das wäre so nicht.
Aber wo sollen wir Biopsy einnehmen?
Aus der Plurat, ja, Visceral und Pariatalplurat,
da, wo Sie halt Auffälligkeiten sehen.
Wenn Sie keine Auffälligkeiten sehen, kann man trotzdem Biopsyen
und den Pathologen fragen, ob er irgendwelche spezifischen Entzündungen
erkennen kann, ja.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Ja, richtig.
Gut, das war, habe ich Sie ziemlich gelöchert mit Fragen.
Ja.
Gibt es sonst noch irgendwelche Fragen oder Kommentare?
Ich gehe jetzt kurz mal in den Chat rein, versuche mal zu gucken,
was da lohnt für Sie.
Dann habe ich jetzt nichts, irgendwie Tuberkloße,
TVT-Tuberkloße, haben wir gesagt, ja.
Also beim Verdacht, bei Tuberkloßverdacht müssen Sie halt auch gucken,
also wenn die Biologie nichts erbringt,
also Sie machen ja dann meistens so eine Direkt-Ferbung,
Zylnesen-Ferbung, manchmal sieht man das, aber damit ist,
wenn die Negativ-Ws nicht ausgeschlossen,
das heißt, Sie müssen Kulturen anlegen.
Manchmal dauern die Kulturen halt vier bis sechs Wochen.
Und dann kann man, wenn man auf die Kulturen war,
zum Beispiel mal einen Quantiferon-Test machen, ja,
oder für den Tuberkulintest zum Beispiel, ja.
Ich habe eine Frage, Herr Ogras.
Wenn diese Patient ein Stablung gehabt hätte,
was würden wir sehen am CTFibrosis?
Würden wir unbedingt sehen, ja.
Ein pleurer Ergust bei Staublungen ist extrem selten.
Das ist eine Komplikation von irgendwas anderem.
Also normalerweise macht eine Pyromokoniosis kein Ergust.
Normalerweise.
Okay, verstehe.
Gut, sonst habe ich jetzt keine weiteren Fragen
oder Kommentare gesehen.
Okay.